[Musique]
bonsoir dans moins de deux semaines se
tiendra le 1er tour du scrutin des
municipales 2020 les listes ont été
officiellement déposée en préfecture
dans les yvelines on en compte pas moins
de 375 pour les communes de plus de 1000
habitants est parmi celles est déposée
révélé à la dernière minute se mord pas
autrement elle est menée par erwan le
gall actuel premier adjoint à maurepas
qui a donc décidé d'affronter le maire
sortant grégory gars restiez erwan le
gall qui je cite accuse le maire de
compromission avec la république en
marche et de clientélisme
erwan le gall que le maire justement ne
souhaitait pas reprendre à ses côtés
pour un nouveau mandat en cas de
victoire en écoute c'est gregory k
restiez réagir à cette candidature
d'erwan le gall quand vous agissez
pendant six ans il faut le faire dans la
confiance et la sérénité cette confiance
eux n'étaient plus là malheureusement
c'est le gala avait des valeurs qui ne
sont plus forcément les miennes dans le
sens où il s'était radicalisé également
sur ces comportements le rôle du premier
adjoint c'est le bras droit du maire
dans l'ombre et non pas son double dans
la lumière
donc aujourd'hui aucune surprise et ça
me conforte vraiment non le choix que
j'ai fait qu'ils vont gens soient à
présent philippe guilbaud soir
bonjour et bienvenue en plateau vous
êtes le premier adjoint au maire des
clayes-sous-bois sur ce mandat qui
s'achève a depuis un an vous avez
annoncé vouloir prendre la succession de
véronique côté millard qui a décidé de
ne pas se représenter
pour autant vous n'avez pas eu son
soutien direct pour cette campagne et il
ya au total cinq listes qui se
présentent deux issus de l'ancienne
majorité est ce que vous avez un regret
alors que la campagne touche bientôt à
sa fin de ne pas avoir réussi à vous
fédérer c'est exact des pales soutien de
madame le maire actuel mais j'ai le
soutien de la majorité des adjoints et
des conseillers municipaux ce qui pour
moi est le principal nous vous regrettez
on ne peut que regretter dans la mesure
où pendant 19 ans j'ai travaillé aux
côtés de mada côté millard j'ai été
pendant deux mandats son premier adjoint
mais c'était son choix il faut le
respecter
vous l'avez dit puis 18 19 ans vous
siéger au sein du conseil municipal
vous avez donc une part du bilan que
vous portez également de par votre vote
fonctions au sein du conseil municipal
elle qu'est ce qui reste à faire selon
vous aux clayes-sous-bois tout à fait
j'assume le bilan dans la mesure où
j'étais adjoint aux finances et rien ne
peut se faire sans les finances alors
qu'est ce qu'il reste à faire aux
clayes-sous-bois il reste malgré
beaucoup de choses à faire notamment
écouter les clés sienne et les clés
siens c'est pour ça que dans notre
programme nous avons un volet important
sur la démocratie participative
il reste aussi à faire passer et a
commencé à mettre en place tout ce qui
concerne la transition écologique
ce qui n'était pas le cas il y à 19 ans
et encore moins il y à 7 7 ou 8 ans vous
avez dégager une douzaine de thèmes sur
sur cette campagne il ya un trait
d'union entre tout cela c'est le mieux
vivre ensemble
tout ça c'est à dire tout à fait nous
avons dégagé très ce thème dans ses
traits ce thème c'est le mieux vivre
ensemble sur chacun des thèmes on estime
qu' il y a des relations entre aussi
bien l'eau scolaire que la sécurité et
la prévention que la transition
écologique et c'est pour ça que au
niveau de l'ensemble des compétences que
nous aurons dans notre équipe puisque
j'ai la fierté d'avoir une équipe avec
beaucoup de compétence nous souhaitons
mettre en valeur tout cela sur
l'ensemble de l'ensemble de ces thèmes
mieux vivre ensemble faire participer
les citoyens aussi à une forte demande
dans toutes les communes et on le
retrouve souvent sur toutes les listes
il y a il est membre ainsi participative
il y à une forte demande si je prends un
exemple très concret qui sont les
comités de quartier il n'y avait plus de
comités de quartier au niveau des
clayes-sous-bois nous avons décidé de
réinstaurer ces comités de quartier en
plus de leur donner un budget
participatif
voilà et du concret mais si vous êtes
élu ce sera l'une de vos premières
mesures cette démocratie participative
qu'elle serait la première mesure
la première mesure sera de lancer les
mesures principales dans chacun des
domaines parce que il faut être
conscient que tout demande du temps et
tous demandent des finances donc il sera
important de lancer toutes ces mesures
ensemble et elles mettront du temps une
mesure urgente par exemple c'est tout ce
qui concerne la maison
pluridisciplinaire de santé qui est un
de nos objectifs importants et comment
attirer ces médecins d'ailleurs c'était
maison pluridisciplinaire de santé ça
permet de pallier la pénurie de médecins
qui rencontrent toutes les communes
c'est exact c'est pour ça que parmi les
les recettes entre guillemets que je
souhaite mettre en place ou proposées il
y a notamment l' embauche deux médecins
au niveau de cette de cette maison
maison pluridisciplinaire parce que on
sait qu'il y à un certain nombre de
praticiens qui sont à même de dettes
remunicipaliser dit embauches c'est la
mairie qui s'effondrait en s'arrêtant
gauche c'est la mairie qui prendrait qui
prendrait en charge
je sais que cela fonctionne dans
certaines communes je sais que nous
pouvons avoir un appui au niveau de
l'agglomération ainsi qu'au niveau du
département
ce serait d'ailleurs les rares embauche
que nous accepterions de faire au niveau
de la commune parce que nous nous devons
d'avoir un programme finançables
réalisable sans augmentation des impôts
mais parce que j'allais vous parlez des
finances et vous l'avez souligné tout à
l'heure vous étiez en charge des
finances sur le mandat qui s'achève
notamment comment se portent les
finances de la commune à les finances de
la commune se porte aussi bien qu'elles
peuvent se porter malgré tout la baisse
des dotations de l'état cela fait dix
ans que nous n'avons pas augmenté
l'alto de les taux de fiscalité dans
notre commune nous avons continué à
investir
nous avons continué à baisser
l'endettement
donc nous sommes dans une situation
saine mais il reste à continuer à gérer
de façon très rigoureuse
justement pour mettre en oeuvre ce
programme et je personnellement je ne
souhaite pas annoncer des mesures non
finançables je reviens sur les mandats
que vous avez occupé sur le sur la
mandature qui s'achève justement à saint
quentin en yvelines en tant que
conseiller communautaire vous étiez
délégué aux affaires universitaires
c'est à dire que l'université la
formation l'éducation qui est l'une des
premières missions pour pour amer
l'éducation va avoir un point à point
important dans votre prochaine mandature
ces élus exactement nous avons débuté
grâce justement à au département et à 51
en yvelines le déploiement numérique
dans les écoles maternelles et primaires
tout ceci doit se poursuivre bien
entendu nous avons également fait des
plans pluriannuels d'investissements sur
les écoles nous devons nous devons le
poursuivre au niveau des enfants et là
on retombe sur la démocratie
participative
nous n'avions plus de
deux commissions pour les jeunes et pour
les enfants de conseils municipaux nous
allons les risques nous allons les
réinstaurer de manière à faire
participer les enfants au devoir civique
dès le départ un dernier mot concernant
la ville des clayes-sous-bois sur le
mandat qui s'achève il a été question de
construction de l'organisme de
développement de la ville est ce
qu'aujourd'hui il faut stopper tout cela
revoir un petit peu les plans
d'urbanisme
non il ne faut il ne faut pas se fait
par contre il faut revoir le pmu et
c'est aussi un moyen de démocratie
participative puisque nous consulterons
les clés siens il faut savoir
aujourd'hui que la population a baissé
aux clayes-sous-bois nous sommes un peu
moins de 18 mille habitants je ne
souhaite pas avoir une villa à 19 ou 20
mille habitants mais il faut au moins
rester à ce niveau là de manière à avoir
une rénovation urbaine accepté par la
population puisque oakley nous avons
l'habitude de dire que c'est un esprit
village dans une ville merci d'être venu
sur ce plateau pour évoquer cette
campagne qui se poursuit c'est moi qui
vont si les côtés des clayes sous bois
il y aura deux réunions vous concernant
encore le 6 mars et le 11 mars
école henri pro voilà pour les cités et
les agenda complet de tous les candidats
des différentes communes des yvelines
sont à retrouver sur notre site internet
je précise qu aux clayes-sous-bois
quatre autres listes se présentent et
celle d'anne claire frémont soutenu par
à la république en marche notamment
celle de stéphanie jamin revendiquer
écologiste celle d'aurélie d'olivier
pardon augustin pour lutte ouvrière et
celle de nicolas eu et qui est orienté à
gauche voilà le 7-8 politique se
poursuit avec le nouvel invité
[Musique]
la suite de 7,8 politique avec annie
joël pris un assez bon soir et bienvenue
soit vous êtes peut-être de liste taf
tout à faire pour plaisir vous poser
directement cette première question
c'est à dire que vous considérer
aujourd'hui que rien n'a été fait sur
plaisir ah non pas du tout toute affaire
c'est ça signifie que nous avons nous
tout à faire pour changer plaisir
effectivement il ya plein de choses qui
ont été faites et pas forcément qui vont
dans le bon sens voilà donc c'est pour
ça que c'est taf c'est ça sonne bien
d'ailleurs
nous sommes des tapeurs nous allons sur
le terrain et nous voyons ce qui ne va
pas et a pas mal de choses qui ne vont
pas mais ça fait longtemps déjà que je
suis sur le terrain où vous dites qu
aujourd'hui tout a été réalisé dans un
patchwork pardon de projets sans
cohérence c'est ça qu'est ce que vous
reprochez au bilan de la maire sortante
et bien
oui effectivement un patchwork parce que
on ne voit pas le fil conducteur
a priori il n'y a pas de fil conducteur
les projets sont faits en fonction
souvent des subventions qu'elle peut
obtenir ce qui est ce qui est pas mal
d'ailleurs mais pas forcément et peut
souvent avec la concertation en
concertation avec les citoyens avec les
personnes des quartiers sur place qui ne
disons que même si elle les rencontres
et bien et ne les écoute pas parce
qu'ensuite il y a quand même on entend
quand même des discours qui ne vont pas
dans le sens de ce qui devrait être fait
dans ces quartiers là donc effectivement
un patchwork avec des incohérences des
projets qui ne tiennent pas vraiment la
route
on parle de plan cyclable mais ils
n'arrivent pas vraiment on parle de
lorsque le bio est arrivé dans les
cantines dans les restaurations
collectives
finalement ça devait être fait c'était
légal tôt que c'est juste une question
de retard aussi beaucoup de retard dans
beaucoup de choses notamment sur
l'écologie on va parler de justement de
l'écologie c'est un temps de votre
programme important je précise pour
votre liste n'a pas d'étiquette mais
plutôt à gauche clairement à gauche
soutien d'europe écologie les verts
parti socialiste oui clairement à gauche
parce que d'abord soutenu par deux
partis de gauche peu élevé le ps
effectivement moi je suis sans étiquette
je n'ai jamais été encarté je n'ai
jamais fait partie de partis politiques
mais je suis de gauche profonde sommes
profondément pardon de gauche bien sûr
avec cette volonté donc d'engager la
ville dans une transition écologique si
vous êtes élu concrètement ça passe par
quelle mesure comme on engage la ville
dans cette transition écologique et bien
au langage d'abord c'est une écologie
politique ça ne signifie pas qu'on
laisse de côté les comportements dans le
quotidien
dans les foyers bien sûr les gestes les
petits gestes sont importants c'est une
chaîne construite importante un fil
conducteur qui ensuite amène à des
décisions politiques au niveau communal
donc effectivement un exemple concernant
les appels d'offres et bien tout passe
par le tamis écologique et le tamis
solidarité bien sûr puisque écologie et
social solidarité ça va bien ensemble
puisque ça crée du lien social et nous
on veut recréer des liens entre les
quartiers parce que la configuration de
plaisir effectivement elle est faite de
telle manière qu'il ya beaucoup de
séparation donc il faut recréer des
plans un plan de circulation ou la
marche les vélos sont prioritaires aussi
si vous êtes élu le 15 mars prochain ou
au second tour le 22 mars quelle sera
votre première priorité première
décision est bien premières décisions
déjà de le faire quand même à un audit
de social est aussi financier je pense
que c'est important
et puis ensuite remettre les choses qui
existait notamment on est vraiment pour
la prévention avant la réparation c'est
quand même mieux donc la prévention elle
passe par remettre les éducateurs
spécialisés sur le terrain remettre des
compétences qui ont été évincés ouvrir
les salles de spectacles dès que l'on
peut parce qu'il ya un programme qui est
déjà mis en place mais dès que l'on peut
les salles de spectacles toutes les
salles aux associations de manière
beaucoup plus libre et flexible
écoutez et recevoir les plaisirs oit
pour qu'on mette en place cette nouvelle
gouvernance que nous voulons absolument
pur plaisir
la suite de notre de la campagne
campagne officielle qui débute
véritablement puisque toutes les listes
ont été déposées en préfecture on sait
dorénavant qu'il y a quatre autres
listes sur cette commune de de plaisir
une liste d'extrême droite une liste
lutte ouvrière la liste de la maire
sortante et puis celle de son ancien
adjoint ce qui vous concerne cette
campagne officielle ce temps de campagne
qui reste vous allez consacré à quoi du
porte à porte et bien public nous avons
et oui effectivement une réunion
publique prévue le mardi 10 février
20h30 à plaisir mars
j'ai pas pourquoi je reviens en arrière
peu utile
bien sûr le 10 mars et puis oui nous
allons être sur le terrain pour
distribuer nos tracts
le programme est sorti donc un battant
il faut qu'on présente la liste les 39
membres de cette liste voilà merci
d'être venu sur ce plateau faire un
point sur cette campagne qui se poursuit
à le plaisir je le disais il ya quatre
autres listes ont été déposées et puis
plus globalement au niveau du
département des yvelines il ya 375
listes déposées dans les communes de
plus de 1000 habitants et puis une
petite précision les incendies femmes
qui ont été désignés têtes de liste ce
dont 79 villes seulement juste un mot
sur ce constat c'est encore assez peu il
ya une parité sur les listes mais il ya
peut pas imposer une parité aux enzymes
zone mini 110 110 femmes qui sont
désignés têtes de liste sur 375 liste
c'est pas mal c'est déjà bien ça remonte
et bien merci annie joël prix ou acide
est revenu en plateau c'est la fin de ce
set 8 politique rendez vous mardi
prochain sur tv 78
[Musique]